[Music
] Hi everyone, I'm Dice.
I live in Korea for the new year. I went to high school for the first time a while ago. You may have seen me in Birch
Feed Korean life videos or Korean food videos.
Today I want to talk about Corona in Korea. So let's start.
Let's see
[Music]
So let's talk about how it spread as a kicker in Korea.
First, the first confirmed person got up and rode
[Music]
Until then, it wasn't a serious problem.
I will
make it seriously
2 31 and confirmed children I was a pseudo-devotee in Daego, the
monster node was infected with group jade, and this city called Daego became very
hell.
And I lived in this place called Daegu
.
What was it like back then? I didn’t say anything like ‘Do your own finances,’
but I couldn’t go out
because I was scared because I just had a blockage in the part and Shin Joo-ah, I was
going to go up the scrap metal because of university.
When I had work, I always wore a mask and came home immediately after seeing things to see
There were a lot of events like , but they canceled one by one,
and in the
end, it was announced that our school was teaching all online classes like
this.
But I moved to Seoul to go to university. I got a response.
Then there was no reason for editorial to come
I promised to have dinner with my friends before, and again, Choo Sarang.
You in Korea are the most fun now that you are passing through college.
But I'm so sad.
Oh, Korea again, to overcome Corona  I am putting in a lot of effort
. Among them,
there is one thing that I think is the coolest. When a
certain person occurs, an alarm is sent to the cell phone,
and I check all the places that the confirmed person has passed.
And those places die and make a profit
And please tell people about the routes so that
we can avoid it, not only the castle on the left, but now even if we go yesterday, the
elevator-like buttons have a film with a scent like
this.  No matter where I go, I have to check ok Malaga 10. Also, if
you use public transportation such as buses or subways, the situation is dangerous right now. There is a broadcast telling you to be alert.
They checked all the heat and gave gloves to the bean.
And they voted and they told me to see plastic gloves like this. It was very
strange.
4 First of all, the perception that we need to wear a mask from the very early days continues to rise, so
now when we go out on the street, everyone is wearing a mask.
Uh, the economy is now in a very downturn. It's not as much as before, but there are many shops with the same door. So, a campaign for good landlords that landlords lower
rents is also being implemented now
.
I've seen a lot of cases where Gaga makes and sends a lunch box. I've
heard of people making masks and making blankets for public institutions like this. The
most interesting thing is that the Kiryu company gave alcohol to the hand sanitizer company
like this. That's me.  I think it was impressive. And again, when it comes
to collaboration, the most important thing is to get an inspection. In
Korea, there is no inspection.
So, if you are in doubt, tell me the manual. You can
come to the hospital according to the menu.
And if I am not overseas, I am proud of the confirmation.
If you are eligible, you can get a free test.
However, even if this does not apply to Korea
, because Korea has a well-established health and medical insurance system,
anyone can receive an examination for only 160,000 won.
Then again
, the method that is becoming a hot topic these days is the
life test method. Literally, if you get fat and
pass like this, it takes about 15 minutes and the
test result comes out in one day or two
.  I think they are well-
prepared. There are a lot of masks in Korea,
so the day you can buy them is determined according to the way you were born. Also,
local governments are providing several masks per person.
The mask is a little lacking, but the food is not lacking at all. When I go to the
mart, I just buy something different from usual. Well, if I
have to find a change, I think I eat out and eat a lot of delivery.
Korea has a very good one-month culture.  It's
not working, so life gets steamy. Because you just eat, you wear a mask or
participate in two social curries. I hope you can join us in ending Corona quickly and quickly with such trivial canons.
Actually, I'm a little worried because the weather is getting warmer now.
Because of me, the corporate institutions that have worked hard because of me are getting longer, so
I am a little worried that people will collapse and give up because of me.
end me like that  I wish I
could
throw it away So if you're dizzy then go out and don't be in a hurry to watch Gun speed women
or see the corresponding award on my channel I recommend you to see purity